[Music]
how much would I take today to sit in
the room when Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
had their first meeting and I was like
how are you super weird like I pay a lot
the number one thing I always say to
myself when I think about that what
would I pay the most money for is to be
in the room the day somebody decided to
sell you got your perspective hello
world my name is Tyler Schmitt we're
here in LA I have the new office full
day bouncing around la guy did some
client stuff this morning 8 a.m.
coming into the office although four DS
because hiring is guessing firing is
knowing
and then tonight USC talk which will be
cool six hours in LA
Gary will be here soon whirlwind will be
created meetings will be cancelled Muse
will be moved and we will keep rockin
and rollin one day at a time here we go
[Music]
Sceptile oh I'm ready
I bought 173 giannis rookie cards in
August for a buck 50 now they're 380 and
the markets liquidus [ __ ]
I believe the culture is gonna go into
it yeah but Jordan rookies I bought for
3,200 in August
they're training at 6,000 you know you
go out and buy [ __ ] what is the eBay
it's liquidus [ __ ] that if Tyler bought
some [ __ ] sticker of some soccer kid
he hit scores a hat-trick what's what
happened in one day I was 18 or 35 and
I'm about to personally push it like I'm
about to like like I'm gonna turn card
dude what's that amazing
that's so good how about this Schomberg
decide on your earth how about this
somebody found it I I haven't seen it
yet because I didn't have the software
before no I haven't seen yet he made on
her I come down with a sign that says I
love the Jets on the side
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] I can't believe I did that I'm
[ __ ] crazy literally it makes no
sense
Ivan need to hack WrestleManias and push
jets propaganda that's basically my 20
year plan every 20 years I've hacked
Wrestlemania with jets propaganda I want
to be I'm probably gonna be in
Wrestlemania
I swear to God I would pay right now
this is why I started filming I would
think five foot so I believe one day
somebody will actually be sitting in
this seat and paying my
great-great-grandchildren nine dollars
for the right to do it
I believe that VR will get so advanced
that the library of my content will
allow for people to actually feel like
they're sitting in this room right now
in 57 years so when I thought about that
that's a hypothesis of mine I know it's
a little weird but I kind of like
weirdly believe it so then I started
thinking if I believe in that hypothesis
how much would I pay today to sit in the
room when Steve Jobs and Bill Gates had
their first meeting and I was like how
are you super weird like I pay a lot the
number one thing I always say to myself
when I think about that what would I pay
the most money for is to be in the room
the day somebody decided to sell bottled
water I don't know why but I'm so
fascinated by it like it comes out of
the sink for free and somebody literally
just goes we're gonna sell it and like I
have to assume the only cop I have right
now is if I look you dead in the face
and said like I'm really gonna sell
oxygen straight up I'm heading to Rich
Eisen show Rich Eisen a iconic sports
commentator
former ESPN I'm talking about draft I
guess jet season I don't know definitely
gonna be lit because I get excited on
there you cannot use MVP as a variable
to a sports debate it is a ludicrous
data point is not you were talking about
sports cards and heavily to the economic
guys why do you think that you're able
to see those trends I don't know I don't
know why certain things become obvious
to me social media the Internet itself
rappers you know first of all I don't
predict anything so like there's an
article on Forbes calm right now that
says sports cards up another 15 percent
as an alternative investment what I'm
good at is actually knowing something's
gonna extend extend I think people see
things that I say I think certain most I
think I'm very good at understanding if
something's gonna be a fad for a month
or a trend for three years that's what
I'm good at
right do you think it's with things
mainly that you're also already
passionate about and potentially maybe
you don't see potentially potentially
yeah well let's start with this I have
to see it I'm not passionate about slime
but I was right about that kids were
gonna play with slime for a while cuz I
saw it playing out I'm not passionate
about skateboarding culture but I knew
that when Lil Wayne started doing stuff
that that urban kids would be wearing
vans
so I need to see it so if you take me to
a heavy metal like you if you bring me
into your world if I play for a week
um though there you I could literally no
nothing like I do right now
about hardcore heavy metal right this
minute and if you give me a week to be
in a cook if I went on tour with a top
10 player studied for a week did what I
did in a week I would be I would have a
hot take an insight a hypothesis that
would be good hmm I feel like we should
play this out you want to go mosh I mean
I don't want to hurt anybody out there
you know what I'm saying
you know if I had more time like like
one day when I truly have time that
would be like a great show where like
every week I go into some crazy new
world and I come out with my hot take
that'd be such a great show I spend a
week right like in like farming and be
like alright my hot pick is you that'd
be really cool actually that's an
amazing show how are you good yes
well hey Jason love your stuff well I
appreciate that say it I like that all
the time thank you thanks for watching
hello sir are you good to see you it's
not what you he just told me the story
of finding your wallet when you found
halo holy Sh do you know about this
Caleb found Rich's wallet at the combine
Caleb finds a wallet opens it your event
I know did you give him the did you know
we kept the wallet we kept the wallet we
still have the wallet thank you sir
watch your step
you want any makeup or anything like
that we can make you look okay cool
what's up everyone
hey how are you guys good to see you
it's great to see you again really
well-seasoned always man are you kidding
me man has a family great how about you
everything is really go my brother had a
baby today yeah hey J hat EJ had a baby
happy uncle and uh hello how are you
guys hello wrote hoping that the
schedule would be released today so we'd
have the jet schedule and is it supposed
to come today tomorrow is so tomorrow at
8 o'clock at night but I already know a
lot about schedule okay sorry taco if
you want
yeah I'm read you know you know the
first game of seasons Jets Cleveland
Browns Monday night suppose it was
leaked but is it fake news was it real
it was definitely firm a little while
ago and then they've instead they unfirm
dit and but I still think it's coverage
it's a 50th anniversary Monday Night
Football
it's the 100 it's the 100th season in
the NFL and they're it's all about a
great ball it's the first ever Monday
Night Football
who's gonna that's watching Odell I mean
we'll discuss it come on out we'll do
this
here we go
wadding he boxes in the Hall of Fame but
he made it or he's a finals through the
half here on the program I could spend
the entire time that what I have with
this man by introducing him but he's the
chairman of Vayner X the active CEO of
vaynermedia you follow him on Instagram
and Twitter at garyvee oh god I could do
this all day I might I might have to
retire my career has a really funny
moment in it which is when I went double
down on Boehner like mm September 2011
to like 13 14 I was pretty quiet for me
on the Internet it was very little like
there's only the key if you look at it
there's only like the keynotes there's
like a couple things like I was very
quiet and then when I came back I was
more self-aware and what did I start the
askgaryvee show I mean I sometimes when
I talk to Caleb or anybody on my team
like you know I the breakout personality
in the business space in this last
couple years while actively being a CEO
and CEO of a massive company and when I
talk to them like could you imagine if I
was just Gary be like every morning I
would do a [ __ ] morning show from
like 8 a.m. to 11 a.m. just QA and was
like take you think I'm penetrating all
the channels now it'd be over I would do
it every day it's my favorite thing to
do it
tea with Gary Vee you know like nice
glass of tea just put him on call me
boom boom boom boom boom boom clip clip
clip distribute distribute every day
look how pumped we get when we do one of
the reasons I did for these was for the
[ __ ] what I just saved because hiring
is guessing firing is knowing like that
[ __ ] thing's gonna kill on LinkedIn
that's 2 million in the bank
but I need to be asked it's hard to like
self-start
like it's not I apologize I'm really
great at self starting that's why I was
good it's just I only gonna say the same
things that I believe it the only time I
do new [ __ ] is what I'm asked that's why
I started and if you know that about
yourself make it a Q&A show right so fun
especially when you stay and you're the
biggest thing I'll tell you just stay in
your lane I think a lot of people when
they start QA have a sense of like I'm
an expert and I should have an answer
for this like it happened yesterday
I don't know right I have no ego or I've
lived my own truth if I never write
another headline for myself then I
wasn't good enough
I don't know nonetheless I'm super
pumped to tell them I'm like I don't
know
I defined success as waking up and being
happy and being able to do what you want
to do at all times
[Applause]
it's super simple and like and we we are
absolutely at an inflection point where
there's people like me and different
things happening where we're starting to
have different conversations like
nothing freedom is what everybody's
chasing but they're confused about what
it actually looks like it's not how much
you make it's how much you spend there's
a lot of people could be way more free
if they didn't overextend themselves on
what they're buying
[Music]